this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today to celebrate the 25th
anniversary of the resident evil
franchise
he's going to be breaking down the mad
weapons of resident evil 4.
when the player hits what i gather is an
optional reload button for a gun that
has unlimited ammunition for the drum
mag he just
doesn't bother and um reloads his hat
instead
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to video game firearms make
sure to hit that subscribe button
and if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you'd like to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comments section below
if you'd like to help out the royal
armies museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
okay let's pause there resident evil 4
not a game i've played to my shame the
design of the the
i guess is a hero pistol is unusual
there's there are shades of all sorts of
different things in there some people
online
point out the similarity with the
heckler and [ __ ] usp
which is this and i do agree to
to some extent the blockiness of the
slide the shape of the trigger guards
this one happens to have quite a similar
laser sight on it as
the one that's available in the game so
i'm happy to say yeah it's partly usp
based so we have a sort of hyper real
world and so
many elements of it are exaggerated but
unlike many video games especially of
that of this era
where you shoot somebody affects how
they react which is absolutely
realistic so a shot to the limb is
typically
going to slow somebody down or whether
they're um affected by
some sort of virus or not and if it
strikes a bone the bones provide the
support
like a tripod for a camera and if if a
bone is damaged then somebody's going to
go down
now the head shots we see are beyond the
capability of
anything short of a 23 millimeter cannon
so they're hyper real
only in recent years have things like
first person shooters try to sort of
depict what happens
when bullets hit people
pausing there's something a little
sacrilegious
about a c96 mauser with a laser sight on
it
apart from that that's quite a nice
depiction of the c96
specifically the red nine which is the
in-game name for the gun
the red red nine is a nickname for a
nine millimeter parabellum to the luger
pistol cartridge
version of the c96 mauser and it's
called red nine because as you can see
in the in-game model it's got a red nine
on it i haven't got the holster stock
fitted to this one
it's quite well modeled i think but
given the limitations of the of the
generation of hardware that it was on we
see
uh realistic loading so when the
pistol's empty or when you [ __ ] it a
strip a clip of 10 rounds in the top
push that in to remove the clip and
the bolt goes forward the only criticism
i'd make other than the laser sight
is the speed of the bolt i think because
the
the animators want you to notice them
and appreciate
what's going on in front of you they're
too slim but it should be faster than
the eye can
pick up basically
right this is uh another interesting
weapon here it is
and it's holster the pistol being the h
k pekka and [ __ ] vp70 and there's the
vp70m
which allows you to attach the shoulder
stop not just for
stability point of this as depicted in
resident evil 4
is three-round burst in terms of the
depiction three-round burst is correct
but in real life this thing fires so
fast
three shots in very quick succession at
a rate of what must be over a thousand
rounds per minute having heard this
thing fired
you can't tell the difference it's like
a single shot that echoes
is the best way i can describe it but in
the game that wouldn't work because it
would almost work like a shotgun it
would feel and play like a shotgun so
they slow it down they give it the
three-round burst that we see
[Music]
all right uh pause the cult 1911 makes
yet another appearance the depiction of
it here is interesting because it's it's
depicted as being incredibly powerful
more along the lines of a
typical video game magnum revolver and
actually the in-game model to me looks a
bit too
big it's just the big laser sight making
it look bulkier than it is but then
you might be a slight scaling issue
there the the laser sight's
probably worth commenting on because
it's um quite a retro design
what was more typical by this time is
what we see on some of the other pistols
is a little under barrel laser the the
big lasers on the top of the gun
are well you've seen you've seen the
terminator 1984
that was um that was actually too early
they used they cheated that with the
battery pack down
on mr foxmega's sleeve because that
technology was only just starting to be
developed really this is a short window
of time where those
lasers were in any sort of use and they
were too big and bulky
for most people to to use them
moving up from pistols we've got the
tmp machine pistol submachine gun
the definitions are a bit fluid
generally a submachine gun has to have a
shoulder stock and in this variant of
the weapon we do see a shoulder stock
fitted the version i've got here
does not this is the basic tmp
pretty much as it appears in the game
it's not far off
they are riffing on the real designs
they're not slavishly copying them so i
am seeing a bit of a video game trope
with four submachine guns machine
pistols
which is that in real life they are
pistols on steroids they fire the same
ammunition
so they should have the same effect on
target per bullet
as a pistol in games of course you don't
want to replace the pistols
as a category as a class of weapon
otherwise the player will never use them
again for the rest of the game
often we see the damage dealt by
automatic
pistol ammunition firing weapons we see
that damage dialed down
and that's very evident here where we
see enemies just tanking bullets
on the plus side you have greater
capacity in automatic fire so you can
put more bullets on target
it's almost a playstyle choice perhaps
between lots of bullets that are less
powerful
and fewer bullets that are more damaging
the good old thompson i wouldn't
necessarily have expected to see it in
in this game but uh why not it would
work we're far enough into
uh video game graphics at this point
that we have moving bolts
great but um this thing's firing from
the closed bolts which is
if you know your guns you know is not
how the thompson works
unless it's a restricted civilian
semi-automatic version which is designed
completely differently so
we've got uh on the face of it two
different versions of the thompson
the m1 or m1a1 with it with a 30 round
box magazine
and the shoe cargo typewriter drum
magazine version of the gun but actually
it's the same model and they've just
replaced the straight magazine with a
fairly low polygon drum magazine and
they clearly
ran out of time or chose not to include
a reload animation for that because as
we see there
when the player hits what i gather is an
optional reload button for a gun that
has unlimited ammunition on the box
magazine he
rocks it in and out of the gun like an
ak which is also wrong
and then for the drum mag he just
doesn't bother and um
reloads his hat instead which is kind of
curious but also quite funny but
you know gameplay-wise absolutely fine
i'm sure actually it's probably quite
good fun with a
thompson to have unlimited ammo because
the only disappointing thing about a
tommy gun is when it runs out
right pause uh the infinite launcher so
um
interesting concept a recoilless weapon
that does not need reloading it's
obviously the rpg seven because it's
infinite
when the munition is fired instantly
another one appears behind it but that's
that's a gameplay thing
the model itself looks pretty good for
an rpg-7 although
it looks like there's some sort of scope
mount that doesn't have a scope on it
so so the model is a little bit off but
it but it's pretty good the big standout
sort of
red flag realism thing is the tremendous
recoil characters almost sort of mimes
when it when he fires which implies
great power i get that but um the whole
point of recoilless weapon which is what
the rpg 7 is
is there's no recoil then again most
people don't realize that the rpg
is a recordless weapon they think rpg
stands for rocket-propelled grenade
which it doesn't
the other thing which is a tremendous
health and safety hazard the girl that
keeps following leon around
would be dead because she's getting the
back blast
of this recoilless weapon in the face
infinite times
but the way it almost removes the recoil
is by directing the blast
of the propelling charge or the
expelling charge to the rear
and that balances out in newtonian
physics terms
the weight or the mass of the projectile
of the munition that goes out of the
front
but uh looks like the player's having a
tremendous amount of fun with it
so we'll forgive all of that
that was a treat i've not seen anything
quite like that before
full-on sci-fi not based on anything
real we've got an interesting arm brace
for i guess because it's meant to be
like an arm gun now arm guns have been
uh dabbled with people have tried to
create guns that effectively act like an
extension of your arm and are fired
one-handed
that's about as far as the real world
connections go darts with explosives on
them
i'm sure someone tried it in the second
world war but i can't think of anything
off the top of my head
probably more inspired by rambo's
explosive or predators
explosive arrows i suspect but a cool
weapon
definitely and breaks the monotony of
bullet weapons
um we've got uh next something similar
to
the protector or striker shotgun that
came out of south africa
in the 80s and a clockwork mechanism
there's a loading port there which on
the video game version
is just not there and um what i don't
think we see
leon do is lined up his gun
it's almost as though the game version
of the gun has some sort of internal
mechanism that automatically
winds itself in reality it's a simple
clockwork mechanism
wind it up load your shotgun cartridges
one at a time
and then pulling the trigger release
fires the fires the shot that's in line
with the
barrel and then releasing the trigger
clunks the internal drum around to the
next shot
it shows up in all sorts of movies and
video games because it looks
cool and it allows for very rapid high
muzzle flash
high sound gunfire which is what we want
from these things
we've got a sniper rifle here previously
grabbed a springfield
m1903a4 because um the internet tells me
that is
what's in the game i think it's pretty
far removed actually and the basic
silhouette is there definitely but in
detail it's uh
differs quite a bit the thing that stuck
out for me well two
two things really one is the very low
power of the shots
uh normally a sniper rifle whether in
real life or in a game
is higher damage than that so that
surprised me
strangely enough what stuck out was the
zooming of the scope which is
absolutely standard in in computer games
and that technology obviously that
has existed for a while but um if this
really is a
second world first and second world war
vintage sniper rifle
they were fixed magnification and you
couldn't just
rotate a drum or something to zoom in
zoomable scopes became the thing later
on and maybe this is a modern scope on
an older rifle
but of course in terms of loadouts you
need a long
rifle and it allows you to engage from a
distance when people are throwing
explosive
whatever those were at you
we are a museum as you know the royal
armouries if you'd like to donate
or even become a member we have links in
the description we also still have
copies of
my british bullpups book if you'd like
to look at perhaps buying a copy of that
and on our own royal armouries youtube
channel we are
doing a series of short videos on
firearms
featuring me so if you'd like to head
over to the armory's youtube channel
do that as well otherwise thanks very
much take care
[Music]
you